from silora Allah knows his way around
kitchens back in his hometown Hama in
Syria he had his own restaurant but
since he emigrated three years ago he
opened up a Syrian specialty restaurant
in downtown Istanbul he was lucky to be
able to start anew while in exile in
Turkey at first the Turkish neighbors
had reservations they let their feelings
be felt but at one point they accepted
the fact that we have to survive - then
we have a good relationship - most
people here business is good my cousins
and I own 14 shops in Istanbul the
restaurant is in a quarter that people
call little Damascus the three hundred
thousand Syrian refugees in Istanbul
have created an infrastructure for
themselves they own cafés bakeries
travel agencies and real estate
companies the Syrians here have settled
many of them want to stay in Turkey the
Turkish government rejects criticism of
its refugee policy they are pointing at
the improvement Syrian refugees in
Turkey nowadays get work permits and the
free healthcare
these young Syrians say that's only half
the truth for them there are still
enough reasons to leave Turkey and
continue on to Europe to try their luck
we can work here but the pain is
terrible and we're not insured lawyers
are not obliged to pay insurance for
Syrians medical procedures have to be
paid for only surgery is free and
state-run hospitals plus we have to pay
for medicine in Syria I had my own shop
but here I have to work as a waiter in a
cafe 15 hours a day and I get half of
what a Turk earns any there's no future
for me here I'm going to stick to my
goal of going to your agency after Mecca
and Sun that's why here in little
Damascus the life vests salesman will
continue to do good business with
migrants